[Música]
son mis sobrinitos emma y tomás y estoy
segura que ustedes concuerdan conmigo
que como niños de 3 años pasan todo el
día jugando inventando explorando y
fabricando y también estoy segura que
concuerdan conmigo que estos procesos
son trascendentales para el desarrollo
cognitivo y el aprendizaje de emma y
tomás por ejemplo están de acuerdo que
cuando emma le dijo a la mamá que estaba
construyendo un chai ling con sus trucos
emma no solamente está aprendiendo sobre
este dibujo animado sino que además emma
está desarrollando habilidades motoras y
espaciales está aprendiendo sobre
figuras formas y colores o que por
ejemplo cuando tomasito utiliza la
tableta de la mamá para generar
secuencias de muñequitos y luego él
imita esos pasos como si fueran pasos de
baile
todos aquí concordamos que tomás es un
excelente bailarín pero más importante
aún toma se está reconociendo patrones y
resolviendo secuencias lógicas y no
solamente ustedes y yo podemos concordar
que estos procesos de jugar y fabricar
son esenciales para el desarrollo de
hematomas de hecho desde hace más de un
siglo grandes pedagogos y pedagogos que
estoy segura que todos aquí han
estudiado como montessori freire piaget
paper todos ellos coinciden en lo
importante que es hacer para pensar y
aprender haciendo y están bien gracias a
ellos que hemos sido realmente en en los
últimos tiempos exitosos en incorporar
esa fabricación en las experiencias de
aprendizaje de nuestros niños y jóvenes
sin embargo también ustedes estarán de
acuerdo que conforme nos vamos alejando
de esa primera infancia del primero y
del segundo ciclo ese hacer y fabricar
se vuelven cada vez menos visibles en
nuestros sistemas formales incluso
asociamos estas acciones como si fueran
acciones exclusivas de la infancia y
esto es mucho más notorio en el mundo
del que yo vengo la universidad donde
fabricar o jugar son muy pocos grados
como estrategias auténticas para
aprender y esto es lo que define la
pregunta por la que ronda
mi idea hoy y es cómo hacemos para
reivindicar la fabricación en las
experiencias de aprendizaje de la
universidad y cómo hacemos para hacer
justicia a todas estas investigaciones
que nos refuerzan una y otra vez el gran
valor pedagógico de la fabricación y del
jugar
todas las etapas del desarrollo del ser
humano
esto es un gran reto porque implica un
cambio de paradigma no solamente en el
sistema educativo sino también en lo que
hemos incorporado en nuestro imaginario
social como la mejor o la única manera
de aprender en la universidad
estoy segura que algunos de los que
están aquí han visto este m o diferentes
variaciones de esto
esto tristemente es una realidad en
muchas de nuestras universidades nos
podemos identificar en la universidad en
la que yo trabajo asumimos el reto de
romper con esto y estamos integrando
múltiples estrategias entre estas un
espacio que hemos denominado laboratorio
de aprendizaje
lo llamamos laboratorio porque todos los
días ponemos a prueba diferentes maneras
de mejorar las experiencias de
aprendizaje de nuestros estudiantes y es
un espacio de aprendizaje porque a pesar
de que nos estamos inspirando en esta
tendencia mundial de fabricación digital
que se promueve por ejemplo en los
espacios makers en los fab labs nos
enfocamos principalmente en lo que se
aprende cuando se fabrica por ejemplo
esto es que ustedes ven acá son
estudiantes de la carrera en
administración de aduanas y en este
momento ellos están súper concentrados
resolviendo diferentes casos
colaborativos en esos casos en realidad
lo que están haciendo es jugando esto es
un juego donde ellos utilizan diferentes
piezas o objetos físicos que simbolizan
diferentes categorías o conceptos
aduaneros así como cuando nosotros
jugamos monopoly y utilizamos la piecita
del carro de la casa del dinero y le
atribuimos un valor a esas piezas aquí
en este juego ellos están utilizando
material concreto para facilitar esa
interiorización de los conceptos y
categorías que son propios de su
disciplina y que ellos deben de dominar
este juego o estos casos de estudio
tienen un requisito previo y es que
algunos de los objetos con los que ellos
están trabajando han sido diseñados y
fabricados por ellos mismos mediante
impresión 3d y que lo que hemos
observado pues bueno que el utilizar
estos objetos de diseño propio original
redefine toda la experiencia le brinda
mayor significancia personal y por lo
tanto los estudiantes se sienten más
involucrados y más responsables de
resolver estos casos de resolver este
juego además estos estudiantes ya
comprenden con mayor profundidad estos
procesos conceptos y categorías propios
de su disciplina
en esta otra experiencia lo que estamos
observando es un grupo de estudiantes de
la licenciatura en docencia y en este
momento ellos están poniendo a prueba un
objeto que acaban de programar
integrando computación física lo más
bonito es que ustedes pueden ver ese
momento eureka donde ellos mismos se dan
cuenta de que lo lograron
lo que sí toque confesarles es que no
todos empiezan esta experiencia con
estas emociones de alegría y orgullo que
se ve en el vídeo de hecho algunos o
casi todos inician con un poquito de
miedo e incertidumbre incluso algunos
son escépticos de porque ellos tienen
que aprender sobre programación o
computación física
sin embargo conforme la experiencia se
va desarrollando estas emociones se
transforman rápidamente en las emociones
que podemos observar en el vídeo y ellos
terminan convencidos de lo importante
que fue para ellos haber vivido de
primera mano estos fundamentos del
constructivismo y el construccionismo
estos son estudiantes que ya son
docentes en ejercicio en diferentes
niveles desde preescolar hasta
universidad y a través de esta
experiencia ellos reflexionan sobre
sobre cómo trasladar estos fundamentos
del constructivismo y el
construccionismo a sus diferentes
contextos educativos con o sin
tecnología digital
además reflexiona sobre algo muy
importante y es sobre esas mismas
emociones que ellos están sintiendo y el
papel que esas emociones tienen sobre lo
que se aprende y cómo se aprende
y espero que alguno sepa en qué curso
creamos estos cómics tal vez por los
títulos pueden sacar en realidad estos
cómics son creaciones de estudiantes del
curso de derecho penal en este curso los
estudiantes construyen sus propias
historietas digitales o cómics para
explicar de manera novedosa diferentes
leyes y códigos que ellos tienen que
comprender entonces estos cómics
reflejan desde situaciones cotidianas
del derecho penal hasta situaciones un
poco más complejas o rudas relacionadas
con delitos sexuales o corrupción
estos cómics representan romper como una
tradición
estoy segura que tal vez algunos de
ustedes aquí sepan que las clases de
derechos son tradicionalmente
magistrales con muchísima materia y
mucha información que memorizar aquí
estamos tratando de romper con eso
devolviéndole el protagonismo a los
estudiantes quienes en esta construcción
de estos cómics son corresponsables en
conjunto con su docente de ese ejercicio
de interpretación de la jurisprudencia
vigente que generalmente es un ejercicio
nada más hecho por el docente aquí no
aquí los estudiantes tienen que
plasmarlo en estos cómics ustedes se
imaginarán que ya de por sí crear un
cómic que sea atractivo es todo un reto
pero que además ese cómic explique de
manera clara y correcta esas leyes
códigos y normas
todo un gran ejercicio de análisis y
sobre todo de síntesis de información
que en su origen es una información muy
compleja
como estas experiencias tenemos otras
para otras carreras y lo que hemos
aprendido de estas experiencias es que
no es necesariamente contar con un
espacio o una tecnología en específico
lo que define las experiencias de
aprendizaje activo exitosas en realidad
lo que hemos visto es que hay tres
elementos esenciales el primero es que
todas estas experiencias nunca dejan de
lado lo curricular de hecho estas
experiencias fueron diseñadas desde un
inicio para alcanzar un objetivo
educativo específico del programa de
estudios de cada curso el segundo
elemento y es muy importante es que
estas experiencias tienen un valor
adicional y ese valor adicional es
aportado por la fabricación y todo lo
que implica fabricar con otras personas
por ejemplo comunicar ideas negociar
llegar a soluciones creativas
y autorregular el propio proceso de
aprendizaje y además desarrollar un
pensamiento más integral más complejo
es por estas experiencias que también
nos hemos dado cuenta de que hay un
elemento indispensable y ese es el
tercero y es que han sido diseñadas y
puestas en práctica en conjunto con los
docentes a cargo de cada uno de estos
cursos nunca son dejados de laos de
hecho no se les impone una manera de
trabajar partimos del modelaje y el
acompañamiento para hacer evidente una
manera práctica de integrar la
fabricación para aprender y es así como
ya muchos docentes se han animado y han
trasladado estas experiencias que
ocurren en el laboratorio a sus aulas
regulares adecuándolas a sus diferentes
contextos y necesidades
y es que como le mencioné al inicio
desde hace muchísimo tiempo que tenemos
claras cuáles son las condiciones
esenciales para aprender lo que sí es un
poco nuevo es que esas condiciones se
hagan realidad en la universidad es
decir que finalmente cambiemos el
paradigma y le hagamos justicia a
nuestros estudiantes y no sólo pensando
en el futuro y los que vienen de camino
como mis sobrinitos sino y esto es
urgente principalmente por ellos por los
estudiantes universitarios que tenemos
hoy en las aulas quienes se merecen que
esas mejores condiciones para aprender
se hagan realidad ya
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]